have you ever been cheated on and how
did you find out
yeah I've been cheated on um I've had
two boyfriends and they've both cheated
on me
I think the first time I found out was
through my friend she found some
messages and sent them to me and the
second time a video of my boyfriend
actually got put on YouTube
of him on FaceTime to another girl doing
not so good things what I found the
video how did you
I like how how was he filmed like who
filmed it it was like someone scream
recorded the FaceTime call and I got a
message on Instagram and this woman
basically said like if you don't give me
money I'm gonna post it I was like go
ahead post it I said if he's cheating on
me well I'm not gonna help him yeah yeah
is he is he famous why did they put him
on YouTube
I think she just wanted like like
attention but it got taken down anyway
so
what was he doing on there
well you know you know when you go on
FaceTime sometimes like guys gonna face
time to a girl and though you know we
pulled out yeah it
is he a girl or a shower
he said he was a grower but no that's a
lie
when you're going around here um
so yeah I've been cheated on before
um once to my knowledge
um and basically it was a long time ago
but I found out two years later because
I started dating without knowing again
one of his friends and then his friend
told me oh by the way three years ago
crazy and you're not with that guy no
more yeah
what's the point of doing that yeah it's
crazy obviously by that time I didn't
care but what's the point maybe yeah
maybe if we will make him look better or
something yeah I mean it did you guys
respect a man that does that no way
Chase is not loyal I mean I won't even
respect a girl doing that do you get
what I mean like I would commentary as a
woman no not even that like if me if I
if my friend cheated
on a guy and then he was then dating me
I wouldn't be talking about her
especially at the time if I didn't tell
him why am I telling him after you
wouldn't really be dating him anyway I
wouldn't date him but just say even if
it wasn't yeah even if by coincidence I
didn't know that was her man and he was
to come in my life I wouldn't then
because if I didn't tell him then why
would I tell him now to get by me no
point fetching up the past yeah I kind
of wish he didn't because I just got
hurt for no reason basically but he's
already discharge it did you break up
with him immediately
um well I wasn't I wasn't with him
anyway like I found out three years
later so I wasn't even with him it was
such a weird one so yeah I guess it was
good that you found that later because
yeah I mean it's less heartbreaking in
that sense but it still hurts like oh
okay then you need to know yeah like I
just I'd rather have not known that's
the truth I was fine
it is what is
okay that's crazy
um yes I have been cheated on before I
just had that instinctive when I said I
wasn't through his phone I literally
just went on his phone and I saw
everything I needed to see when you see
who shall find didn't it yeah that's
what a guy told me a guy told me if you
look at any time you always find
something you have an issue with I don't
think you will no but I just got hand at
the front in front of me it was right in
front of me hold down so it's like I
just I was like oh what did you what did
you find
um
a lot of messages okay he was like what
are you doing for Valentine's Day
um
so you're going with that [ __ ] over
there okay have fun that was literally
how it was did you dump him right away
um or did you did you stay with him for
a little bit for how long
um it's always the way yeah
for four more months and then did he
cheat again
the trust was lost and it was just like
that's always the way
um if you went through his phone and you
didn't find anything would you have told
him you went through his phone
the thing is so he just kind of like
gave me his phone and it was like on
open yeah that makes sense like all the
messages were right in front of me that
was God
so it's like
I don't know maybe I would have told him
I went through his phone okay like yeah
yeah I would have yeah okay go ahead
gosh my story is a bit long I don't know
how much time I've got are you thinking
if it's interesting go ahead
um yeah it's okay so basically
his cheating was never confirmed he's
always denied it even though I've got
substantial evidence to say that he's
cheated on me he will still deny it
um
he so
at Uni there was three of us or four of
us that were friends there was three
guys and then me
um and then when I broke up with my
partner at the time I was only about 19
or something
um I started dating him he was like a
friend that obviously I'd known him for
about two years like homie Harbor yeah
yeah because me I like I like to be
connected to your mind to get what I
mean and he was he was like the friend
didn't work out so you're like oh
there's his friend and then no no no no
no no so he was my friend so we were
almost he like made it out of the he
made out of the friend zone oh but but
he was friends with your ex too no no he
was all so we were just a uni friends we
were just a bunch of friends and then so
yes when I became single they all
approached me and I chose him oh okay
okay okay yeah but that you're there was
there was no connection with it yeah it
was just I was single for the first time
and it was just like okay cool
um so
I was dating him we were together for
about I'll say two years and in between
that I found a few things but he'll
always deny it cool I then moved into a
property with one of our mutual friends
girlfriends so one of the girl guys from
the circle his girlfriend
and me and her live together they then
moved in with us because they were meant
to get their own property but it was
just like we might as well just like all
live in one place so it was like cool
everyone used to come to our house it
was like the uni little hot spot my
friend that was dating the girl
he went away so he went to his country
and he was there for some time and I
started noticing a different behavior in
her like her her pajamas started getting
shorter they started going out at the
same time or they'll try to stay in at
the same time and I thought this is
getting a bit awkward like
anyway she they then disappeared one day
at the same time she said she's going to
see her mum he said he's going to see
his mum and we had a group chat they're
not responding on anything you know at
the same time so I thought is it me or
like is this too much of a coincidence
anyway
um when I when I asked him well I said
to him there's definitely someone she's
cheating with because she's you know
dressing up a bit more she came home
that night and she was talking about
like you know she was talking about some
crazy stuff so I was messaging him like
oh I think I know like she's definitely
cheating but I think I know who really
feels like yeah try find out I was like
okay so obviously you know then the next
day he disappeared for the whole night
she disappeared for the whole night so I
thought nothing of it cool I went back
to the flat Alone
um
the week later we had all our uni
friends come round and one of her Dopey
friends came and she didn't know how to
use just eat so she's taking her laptop
now to go and just eat as she's gone on
to put the postcode in she obviously
doesn't know how to use a laptop so I
said okay let me try use it I've gone to
click on the postcode and it says cr0
and I'm thinking she doesn't have no
friends in Croydon like who the hell
where's she going in Croydon so I've now
memorized the postcode and I'm not going
to him like yo yo give me your phone I
think I know who she's cheating with and
he was like yeah yeah like try it try it
like see what you know so I've now gone
and put in the postcode and oh sorry
before I get there basically when he
came back from his night away we had a
massive argument he left the house I
went through his pocket and I saw a
receipt for Hallmark hotel right so
obviously he came back he explained that
he was at his mum's but he needed
um some time away from her so he just
booked a hotel for himself I said why
didn't tell me anyway yeah cool long
story short he needed some time alone so
as I've now gone to put the postcode on
his phone the pin drops at Hallmark
Hotel wow oh so they were together well
this is it so straight away in the whole
group of friends I've now confronted her
and I said how the hell do you know
Hallmark hotel and because he's such a
good Prof prolific liar he goes I made
her order me food
I said sorry and then he's now told me
that he's got her to order food because
he couldn't trust anyone else to order
food because everyone else would have
told me he's at the hotel
so long story short yeah I found out he
was cheating with my flatmate
and did you break up with him
no because he convinced me that that it
was that it wasn't did he really can
like come on no he couldn't
when I said you wanted to be convinced
no no why are saying he convinced me I
called my friend straight away and I
said listen your girlfriend's a cheat
blah blah blah this is what's happened
he then spoke to her apparently she
showed proof that they were they called
for the food or what whatever so he then
convinced me that his girlfriend wasn't
cheating on him she he then made me feel
bad that I'm even making such a big
allegation I still said yeah I'm still
moving out I'm not gonna lie like I gave
him my notice
um so yeah he convinced me that they
didn't do a thing so how long did you
stay with him after that a good two more
years two more years and are you oh
you're the most interesting part
um what made you switch like from being
convinced to not convinced I was never
not I was never fully not convinced oh
okay so yeah you said you said he
convinced you yeah he tried convincing
to me so obviously I still stayed there
so okay this is foreign
so what was interesting is
um so a couple of years later now
university has happened and we've all
graduated you know she was a [ __ ] on
graduation cool
um we've all me and my friend we broke
up because he felt like we I broke up
the Friendship cool
um then a couple of years later I was at
home like we were living together and
then I was going through
I was on laptop and we used to download
you know like we had LimeWire or
whatever then so you just download shows
and as I was going on um a show to watch
the profile a folder came up and it said
please insert USB and her name was a
show that we used to watch so I won't
say the show because obviously it was
disclose who she is but it was she had
so I thought it's the show that he was
watching right it was on his recently
viewed so I've gone to click here and it
says oh please insert the USB
so he's always have USB on his keys so
I've now inserted the first one and it
wasn't showing so I'll inserted the
second one and it came up with a folder
and it had all her pictures oh wow
so I've now gone onto my computer to go
see what like what's on what else is on
there and there was no folders and like
no files and I was like this is so
confusing and I was I'm not tech savvy
like I don't do technology so I've had
to now go on Google find how to unhide
folders I've gone to unhired folders and
there was about 60 folders of girls
pictures that he must have been chatting
to over the time and he was saving them
wow
he just had a file Bank in it oh were
they like naked explicit yeah whatever
like whatever folders he had like so so
when so when was that that was that was
the end of our relationship okay that
then it actually ended yeah okay yeah
then I found out that he was actually
then cheating on me with his ex
oh so that's what how many how many
girls total
a lot I I still wouldn't he'll still
deny but what did you with the weights
so so you found you found a picture like
a whole folder of naked girls multiple
pictures it wasn't even just naked the
sun might have been just oh okay
innocent ones right but it was a part of
his collection and he said and he said
that this is nothing yeah he told me
that he she only like the gold the
flatmate only sent him pictures because
he was giving her advice on what to wear
I was like what you got one like what do
you mean you're advising her but yeah
that was It was obviously you know um he
tried lying as much as he could okay and
then that was the end of the
relationship yeah yeah okay uh
actually was there anything we missed in
the story okay so basically oh there's I
just felt sorry I just felt like you had
more to say
basically his girlfriend his ex at the
time I used to see messages from a girl
called s coming up and I had doubts it
was his ex right and he was like no no
no it's not anyway when I found that
them pictures he then said you know what
I can't do this anymore like I'm done
you're always doubting me I said yeah
because there's reasons cool then
obviously he broke up with me then the
next day I had taken the number s's
number and I called it the next day and
I said oh hey so and so is you know who
with you
and I heard him start laughing at the
background and he had a very specific
laugh so it confirmed that he was with
her but obviously she denied it she was
like why would I be with him but yeah so
so you kind of had like red flags like
all four years would you say
pretty yeah pretty much yeah okay and I
stayed like a dumb girl yeah okay but
the first instance you caught him
cheating you said
well obviously I had the doubts over the
four years right yeah yeah yeah go ahead
um no I've never had an experience like
that
um or I don't know if a man's cheated on
me I don't know about it I don't search
you know okay you don't know no no it
might have happened but you just don't
know I just don't know I don't look for
the thing is with men if you look for it
you'll find it if you want to find it
talking to you yeah oh yeah yeah same
problem
um yeah I don't look for that kind of
thing so yeah as far as I know no but
maybe okay
um let's start here yeah
um I reckon I have I never really saw
anything
in particular but I had very strong
convictions that I was and then you know
like when this is why I say sometimes
people don't talk to your mic sorry yeah
men like I'm provoked because I I knew
but then I'd ask him and then sometimes
he'd say no and then other times he'd be
like oh yeah because you know what I'm
making feel safe I'm like no just tell
me the truth it's fine
and he's like okay yeah and then in
other times when I do bring up he's like
I didn't say that I'm like yeah you did
so I never really found anything
properly but I just I really need you
think you wanna know
no do you know what I can handle the
truth I never ask questions if I can't
handle that answer but I will be
ignorant I will happily live ignorantly
but I would ask a question when I know
that I can handle the truth and I think
doesn't matter what it is the matter
doesn't matter how bad it is please
always tell me the truth yeah I don't
care how bad it is but yeah it's easier
just to be truthful always like don't
waste anybody's time then and I hate
women are like oh you can't handle the
truth and it's like no I can say
no I think someone kind of handed the
truth though I think sometimes we I
think sometimes women say you can handle
the truth but you actually can't because
I think and I think that's why a lot of
guys would then like even like each
other because a lot of women with like
general just tell me and we'll talk
about it but when he then tells you the
truth it's now a whole argument it's a
whole thing you can't you don't you
don't have a proper conversation about
it which is why I love them lie about it
you know where a lot of girls go wrong
men will test whether they can be
truthful of you throughout the
relationship yeah and you don't Club
those little tests where you might say
something and see how you respond to it
it might not be a big thing but that
response tells us a lot about how you
behave yeah so when it comes to the big
things there's no way for me to tell you
anything no but you know what it is the
response she gives you when she first
finds out when she says she can handle
the truth is going to be far better than
when she finds out you've lied to her
because that's when she's vandalizing
your car do you know what I mean if he
gets quiet if he gets caught the
reactions are far worse so even if she
says she can handle it and she reacts
it's going to be a lot more better than
when she finds out that you've lied on
top of that absolutely I've seen women
with the same energy can't remember like
you I'm like I get why the cat the guy
was scared in the first place
huh I don't think guys can handle the
truth any better no they can't they they
definitely I will die
my immune system will shut down hold
down the spot if we told you the truth
about all the things that like we
thought when you asked for our opinion
oh yeah dead yeah I'm I'm on this whole
day don't do it I'll go I'll end up in
hospital I'm glad that you admit that
Eagles fragile serious what about you
Auntie
yeah a few times a few times
I can think of two times two different
times
and once
my boyfriend at the time was supposed to
we're supposed to go out he didn't turn
up so
I went to his house and young lady
answered the door oh yeah
and this is you know
and she goes oh he's upstairs and said
oh I'll come up
and he was in bed are you saying freezer
and he just looked like threesome he
likes to have a heart attack all the
colors just drained out of his face
I just said hi
would you like a cup of coffee I said
yes please
she went downstairs to get the coffee
and he looked at me and I said would you
want to say
do you want to freak out I said no I'm
not gonna do that I said the poor girl I
said she don't know any different and
she's come up and she was just like hi
and she's trying to cuddle him in bed
because they were in bed and he's sort
of like and I'm saying is that your man
and she said yeah I said hug him up girl
were you the main chick or the side
chick I was the main you were the main
yeah but that was it but I just after
that I just terrorized him nicely who
did she think you were did the right
thing to tell me I was his friend oh god
oh well why would you she's like
because I've got a lot of male friends
and she always saw us with a lot of men
together but obviously the energy you
came up as well wouldn't be someone that
you would assume it wasn't the guy
because he's very calm and Collective
it's not awful no but I should say most
girls their instant response would be to
run upstairs they're even trying to oh
that's
the same time I was like hi I'm here I'm
coming you went to torture you wanted to
talk to him yeah as you should like this
is all right I thought she was concerned
I was his friend
like when I was talking to the guys
because we'd all hang out around this
I'd pop around she said oh he's not in
you know I'm just cooking I got put down
to the shop to get something off and I
said this is what you're having for
dinner right
this is what you're having for dinner
yeah you just want to play it at parties
for me and then he wouldn't invite her
I'm like what do you mean you're not
coming tell him I invited you because
it's more psycho and then no and then I
just left it at that but I didn't I
think he cheated on her because another
time I just saw all of his car had all
painted and I was just like what
happened to you
supposed to do it's not her fault so
moral of the story is pull up
no don't ever
catch him up I'm saying to like torture
him over like time then just like go ham
on them because you could have easily
just taken their jaw off and then that'd
be it over done with taking this jar off
who's your guys
forget about it I hurt my hands
I could never hit a man because if he
hit me back it will hurt so I agree with
that if I hit a man I'd expect him to
hit me but that's what I'm saying that's
why I don't hit him that's that stupid
I'm not gonna hit a man and knowing that
he's going to hit me back
yeah and another time I got cheated on
um I was a supervisor in a bus garage
and I got a phone call my boyfriend was
a night bus driver
and I got a phone call gonna pass a
message on to this person and I said
yeah can I ask you to speak and she said
his girlfriend
I said okay then and I couldn't see any
for a couple of years
and then when he was on his break I said
oh can I have a word he said yeah no
problem
a girlfriend friend she wants you to
phone
he flipped out I was so calm you freaked
out I said to the manager I said you're
gonna need a new driver in a couple of
months it's been a couple of months he
was gone
that was it because and that was one and
the thing is I made him we had like this
relationship contract that I'd signed
and nominated and got him to sign then
it was like you're telling me because if
I find that you cheat that's it yeah and
I hit her so he just flipped out it's in
a personal contract you wrote up yeah I
typed it and everything
wow laminated got to sign it and what I
expected and you break any one of them
that's it
no but I feel that I needed it to do
with it with him yeah
why didn't you freak out like so many
girls when that happens
um like I think a lot of times we have a
hard time like remaining calm
how were you able to control your
emotions I didn't take it personally
it's just a man and he just it was there
available and he just it happens take
notes so you know I didn't take it
personally I mean I didn't think yeah oh
my God she's sexier than me or she can
do this I just thought the opportunity
came up because as far as I'm concerned
you've got a few more friends go ahead
because it could be a female friend
you're gonna sleep with it could be a
woman down the road that you meet up so
it don't really matter so I'm not going
to say you can't have female friends so
we had a female friends and that was one
of them so
um did you break up with him after that
instantly he knew it was over because he
signed the contract yeah what about the
other one instantly yeah what do you
think of girls that stay in those
situations do you think that's good or
bad
then they're going to start talking
about trauma after that
it's up to them but whatever you get I
mean if it can happen once I mean you
can accept it if you want to accept it
but
if you accept it then put up with it in
it don't say nothing yeah because a lot
of times like we accept it and then
complain about trauma later but yeah we
accepted it yeah we put ourselves
through it yeah I'll give that I mean
you've got to think to yourself what
value you're putting on yourself that
you're staying I think a lot of
um women stay with men I think young
like when I was young I was like no I've
never tolerate a man cheating or
whatever but it's harder when you're in
a relationship especially when you're
emotionally involved for you to just up
and leave as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible